david
is in grand rapids hi david welcome to
the dave ramsey show
well hi dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
well my wife and i are worried about
retirement
so we're trying to figure out how much
we need to put away
and where to put it
okay and we have a
household income of uh 80 to 90 000
a year we both have
uh our 401s at 15 percent
and this year we just started a raw good
how old are you guys uh i'm 53 and my
wife is 50.
okay and how much is in there now so we
kind of
between the two of us um approximately
300 000.
good okay got a really good start okay
what's your what's your fear
you're not gonna have enough right okay
well we teach folks to invest and i
personally invest in four types of
growth stock mutual funds
and i put a fourth in each growth growth
and income aggressive growth and
international i'm a little ahead of you
i'm 60
but i've been doing that for most of my
working life
and uh you know putting 15 away and then
later when everything was debt-free i
just
max out everything that i'm allowed to
do whatever i'm allowed to do
roths and 401ks and hsas anything i can
put money into
keep the government's hands off of i do
and i put it all in those four types of
mutual funds
the stock market since it began has
averaged 11
little over 11 actually okay and so if
you're invested in decent mutual funds
you should be in that 10 to 12
range and so if you retired
and um you had a million dollars and you
wanted to pull off
eight percent while earning more than
eight percent on your money hopefully
uh that's what you would have been doing
all these years anyway
uh then that would be eighty thousand
dollars a year
okay if you're invested at that rate
if you're invested in what i'm talking
about uh
you can take your lump sum that you have
now and it will double
every seven years approximately
so seven years from today when you're 59
you'll have 600 seven years later when
you're 66
you'd have one two
that's if you add nothing else tell you
a millionaire would be awesome
that's yeah so if you if you work till
65 and you keep putting in 15
you're probably gonna have two to three
million dollars if you're invested like
i'm talking about now if you're putting
it in a
bank ira making one percent then no
you're not going to do that
but i'm talking about making the 10 to
12 percent range that the stock market
is averaged
in decent mutual funds okay so you need
to align with that to hit those goals
but that 300 will double once and then
it'll double again
by 66 if you're 52.
that sounds wonderful yeah so you're on
track you don't have anything to wring
your hands about but you do need to
watch it
be diligent continue to do the investing
and
make sure you're invested in those types
of things and if you're not
you may want to sit down with one of our
smart vester pros
uh you can click smart investor at
daveramsey.com these are the people we
recommend i'm not
they don't work for me i'm not in the
investing business i personally use the
smartvestor pro to help with my
retirement i'm sure you guys do too we
do and what's so interesting even in his
question
i hear this a lot whenever i'm hosting
the show with you dave is the unknown is
so scary to people
as soon as you laid that out for me he's
like oh well great okay it's like the
confidence goes up i can see how it's
possible i know what i need to do but
sometimes
things that are technical difficult or
just even unknown can feel really
overwhelming and really scary
and that's why i love the smart vester
pros because they walk you through it
and show you
exactly what you need to do and show you
the path and the numbers or even
something simple like chris hogan's riq
tool you plug in the numbers and you see
what you need to retire
whatever it is just being able to see it
immediately
helps you just okay okay i see what i
need to do
yeah it's i mean for me as a nerd it's
easy to understand but what you're
saying is numbers
when they're accurate can uh relieve
stress and give you hope
yeah yeah when you know what they are
i'm gonna go okay i have a hundred
thousand dollars in debt
i make 150 000. oh wait a minute i could
put 50 000 of that a year
on it and i'd be debt-free in two years
those are numbers i could be debt-free
in two years
when you can see it you can do it that's
why we love giving people a plan but you
know even as you said that i thought
gosh i remember when i was in debt and i
remember this was in my late 20s
and i did not i would pay my bills but i
never looked at it all at one time if
you would have asked me at that time
christy how much debt total you have us
i don't i don't know because i didn't
want to face it it was so overwhelming
and scary
but actually when i sat down and listed
out my debts it was like oh
okay i can handle this because now i
know it's not unknown anymore it doesn't
have that power
and over me and i'm able to see this is
what i need to do to take control over
it
it's amazing when you open the closet
door and turn the light on there's no
monster in there
there's no monster in there you know we
all have the monster under the bed we
all have
might be a little gremlin might be a
mouse yeah but it's not a monster it's
not something that can't be
slain it can't be dealt with that's
going to eat you alive it's just
you can deal with it but it's uh you do
need to lay it out and do some
projections and again having some people
in your corner
like a smartvestor pro i mean
i i teach this stuff and probably known
more than anybody in america for
teaching this stuff
and if i passed away today one of the
second or third phone calls sharon would
make would be to our smartvestor pro
because she's going to want to be
reassured again that she's okay
she's been reassured we've shown her the
numbers 26 000 times right
but she's going to want it again right i
know that and so i've got that little
list of phone numbers here's who you
call you know
the corner and then you go and then you
call this and then you call that right
but i mean
and then the smart investor pro is gonna
be one of the right thing because she's
gonna
because if she can go that's right it's
gonna be okay
yeah and it gives you a sense of control
when you list out your debts
see before when it was unknown they had
control over you but now you're like oh
i have control i see what it is i can
tackle it same thing with your
retirement goals when you list it out
it's like oh i've got control now i can
do something about this when people do
their every dollar budget when they jump
in ramsey plus
they have the same experience they go oh
wait a minute where's all their money
going that's right this is
this is silly i can do this that's right
and then you get this sense of power
like you gotta raise that's right
yeah it's just being out of control
versus in control having knowledge
versus not having knowledge
having options versus not having options
this is the dave ramsey show